it's breathtaking
when you see sand here imagine water if
you dive in you can't reach the bottle
you dive in yes it's called swimming I
don't I don't believe you
Shadows of Iraqis lie many secrets
it's the darkest of them all may remain
the end of House of treaties the father
didn't believe in Revenge okay so the
new trailer for June part 2 is here and
throughout this video we're going to be
going through everything in it and
talking about the new characters Easter
eggs and how things relate to the book
we start off with Paula trades and
Cheney sat on a June which A promise is
the best Easter egg that you're gonna
get we're starting off strong and this
is an affectionate moment between the
pair in which he explains his home on
Caledon and how it differs from Life on
arrakis in case you need a quick ketchup
on the events of the Past movie then in
that we join the atrates on kaladan
which was made up of Paul his father the
Duke leader and his mother slash fathers
concubine known as lady Jessica Empress
Dom IV via trades as being a threat
to his Rule and thus he gave them power
of the desolate planet of Iraqis says
way to knock them down the ladder
Jessica is also part of a group known as
the Benny Jesuit who are a coven of Jedi
like nuns that have their hands in both
politics and also religion of the
Millennia they can ingested spice to
imbue them with psychic-like abilities
and this gives them powers to the point
that they're even able to control the
gender of their child before it's born
Jessica was instructed to have a
daughter but Judah her love to the Duke
she went against this and instead gave
him the Sun that he'd always wanted
originally Jessica's daughter was
supposed to be wet to fade who he ended
up meeting in this first look played by
Austin Butler the pair were going to
unite the hawk Conan and arthritis house
which would have hurt the war and
rivalry that they've had for centuries
fade is very much Paul's doppelganger as
both are powerful Sons within their own
houses that will take over rule one day
have you seen the original David Lynch
movie then this is the guy who was
played by Sting I even see a clip of the
final knife either the pair have in the
film come the end of the teaser I love
the way that some of the scenes with him
are shot and we see them in high
contrast black and white which really
makes them jump off the screen this
could potentially be a flashback that
explains a character we'll talk about
later on whilst also giving us
everything we need to know about fade
now Butler is of course coming off the
back of Elvis and he's a great look to
have in the film stinging that first
movie he was memorable yeah but he did
just kind of stand around smirking and
didn't really do much I don't think
they've hammered home enough how much he
was supposed to be a dark version of
Paul but in this teaser I get that idea
instantly now I'm gonna try and stay
away from spoilers as much as possible
as there are some things that will
probably ruin the movie if I talk about
them too much how about we are going
over things that I know the outcome of
so it's a bit difficult to dress them up
as being theories when I'm well aware of
what happens so what I'm gonna do is I'm
just gonna avoid talking about the fates
of characters but I think anything
beyond that like their backstory is
stuff you can know without ruining the
movie for you so that's what I'm just
gonna stick to anyway we begin with
Cheney and Paul discussing calendar
backed it back to that intro shot now in
the prior film she appeared mostly in
dreams with Paul prophesizing that the
pair would end up together she's clearly
taken in by Paul all and no it's just
things we take for granted like water
Cheney sees them as being incredible
this makes Paul seem almost magical even
though it's very straightforward now
this is something that's laced
throughout the subtext of June and even
how Paul's character is portrayed you
see Paul is also supposed to be a
messiah known as the quizzes hadarak
always the pronunciation of that
but to be fair it's quite a difficult
thing to say but a good way to remember
it is
um it was a quiz that had a Raj give a
dog a bone anyway ruin the video there
but Paul is prophesized to be this
Messiah and throughout the teaser we see
the fremin becoming swept up in this
however that's a lie and in case
you missed the subtext in the first film
the betting Jesuit was simply using
religion to manipulate people they felt
they could control the masses by saying
someone was the Messiah now over time
people would start to believe it
themselves and fall in line in following
him that's why when still God sees him
doing incredible things he's caught up
in the belief too and it's is also a
reason why so many people follow Paul in
the end now Cheney Falls victim to it as
well and I'm sure you can guess that the
pair are falling in love without me
putting a spoiler warning over it well
that's made Complicated by the voiceover
we get by Florence Pugh he's actually
playing princess Airline who will be
acting as a sort of narrator in the
movie This ties in with the book and
almost every chapter is headed up by
some narration from her which has been
carried across the air it's also how the
84 films started with her monologuing
all the backstories of the characters in
the beginning Airline is the emperor's
daughter and she somewhat acts as a way
to avert the war which shall not spoil
see I'm nice like that now whilst all
this is going on we see Lady Jessica
being escort across the desert with
bright blue eyes this shows that she's
ingested a lot of spice and I think this
is taking place after the ritual
shinjiers that turns into a reverend
mother she has the markings on her face
and also seems similar the vision that
Paul had of her in the cave in the first
movie it's a complete opposite to how
she was treated in the first film and in
that stelgar refused to take her in at
first until she demonstrated the
weirding way here though she's being
escort almost like she's in a Royal
Carriage which is shaped to look like a
cocoon huge it out to things story for
putting out that she has a crown and
this cocoon could also be a metaphor for
her upcoming rebirth he noticed that the
Cocoon itself has almost snake-like skin
to it and it's possibly hinting that
this is made of a worm anyway in the
book she ingests something called The
Water of Life which rapidly expands the
minds of those that consume it it allows
one to reach across the Galaxy mentally
and make someone become almost like a
god later on in the teaser we see her
gasping for air with her eyes open and
this comes off the back of several
moments with the Benny Jesuit amongst
these shots is Margo fenring who's going
to be played by Leah Sido and she's a
high-ranking member of the group and
she's also Married To The Man Tad has
Amir fenring in case you don't know men
tats are basically human computers and
they often act as aids to houses people
ended up shying away from using
artificial intelligence and instead
these are people who've ingested so much
spice that it makes them like math
wizards they have brains to advance that
they're almost like computers and can
carry a complex calculations in seconds
which makes them very valuable again
lots of law to talk about and not much
time to do it now calling back to that
first film we also get a picture of the
Duke burning which is a similar one to
the Israelis ancestor that we saw
hanging up on kaladan he was wearing a
bullfighter's uniform and as we learn in
that movie it very much tied in with
their history this shows that the
harkonans are destroying every trace of
the atriotes and that they believe they
wiped out the entire line
what if Paula treaties were still alive
foreign
questioning whether Paul is still alive
this could potentially be to her father
who we know is going to be played by
Christopher Walken a Christopher Walken
and talking and I think her asking if
he's still alive could be her seeing if
there's a way to avert the war spice is
the most valuable asset in the universe
because it allows for Interstellar
travel and also because it's used as a
drug rakis is the only place it can be
formed from and because of this it's
very sought after Paul and Co having an
army there could mean that they rise up
and put an end to the emperor's rules so
Airline will probably be a key piece in
the film that will try and put a
peaceful end of the conflict seems like
she's got way more agency than she did
in the 84 film which I think is probably
a better way to handle things among CIS
we get a shot of Gurney confirming that
he survived the attack in the first film
I'm guessing that this movie is going to
cover the major time span that the first
book does due to the length of his hair
at this point compared with the prior
movie Paul and Co were out in the desert
for years but eventually they came
across Gurney during a battle turned out
that he'd hooked up with some Smugglers
and that he'd actually ended up becoming
the leader of them still God was
attempting to take them out I think it
it is quite complicated and then Paul
saw Gurney on the battle and the pair
put their weapons aside this gave Paul a
much stronger Army and he's gonna need
it for the hakonans that we see in the
next shot along with fade we also get
Rabanne who once was played by Dave
Batista he's shown by the baron and
judging by this shot I think that the
family is now back to ruling over arakis
raban is one of The Baron's key team
members and he's someone at the framing
Clash against which may be hinted at in
the next shot and we see some knife
fights on both sides clearly
foreshadowing the big one that comes
between fate and Paul have you ever had
a dream about your first ride
[Music]
you're brave we all know that
be simple
be direct
nothing fancy I understand
nothing fancy
[Music]
so yeah I mean now this bit's pretty
straightforward and here we catch Paul
riding a sand worm for the first time he
attracts Us by using a thumb power which
we also saw popping up in that first
movie I think the scene is important
though as it shows that he too has
self-belief and that he started to bind
to this prophecy this gives him the
confidence to go above and beyond what
others would and it also makes him
believe that he's right now one of the
key plot points in June is about how
damning that prophecy can actually be if
he believes something is morally Justin
right then it enables you to do Terrible
Things June eventually evolves into a
story about genocide and it makes you
question whether Paul was actually a
good man or not because of everything
that happens due to him it's really
thought provoking stuff with it showing
how evil is often done in the name of
good which we know from our own
histories several religions have
murdered people on mass because they
believe that they were right and doing
it in the name of God which Paul also
embodies anyway it's a nice heroic
moment so sorry for putting such a
downer on it mate it looks good and he
gets to ride a giant worm yay now this
of course calls back to what he saw at
the end of the first film and it also
clearly shows the framing that he's
special
[Music]
we gave them something to hope for
that's not hope
May thy knife chip and shatter
[Applause]
and we end the teaser with several shots
of the characters ramping up to this big
final moment that teases at the incoming
War we get ships closing in fade
continuing to clash in the Gladiator
Arena Margo watching on and also a
moment of sexual tension between the
pair later on as I mentioned though
she's known for being married to hasimir
who will be played by Tim Blake Nelson
now we learn in the book that she's
somewhat playing both sides with things
and she's actually revealed to be a spy
I could see her possibly pretending to
love fade so that she can get in fun
things and the black and white stuff
being a flashback could fill in some
blacks Margot tried to warn the Israelis
about the attack in the first movie
which we may see being said appear that
stuff being in black and white and then
this being in color could show that
Fades suspects her and that in this
moment he's questioning whether she's a
spy or not could be wrong with that but
the pair don't kiss or as we see this
happening with Chaney and Paul he
promises he'll never lose her which
we'll see and we also see the captured
fremin leadership she's surrounded by
hakon and soldiers and we can see on the
ground that there's two dead birds these
are actually used as Messengers by the
fremin and them being dead here could
show that they were killed to stop
Communications getting out now we then
get a sunset or moon set with a Ruckus
is certain and two of its moons almost
eclipsing it arrakis has three moons in
tunnel and these are known as krielen
Avon and also one now we close out with
Paul clearly leading a vast Army and
also get a tease towards that final
Knife Fight although the fremin were
thought to be smaller numbers they
actually have them in the tens of
thousands then it leads to poor wielding
an almost Unstoppable Force we see his
cloak blowing in the wind which I'm
guessing is building off the back of
this shot in what looks like him
wandering through the desert Paul says
may thy knife shift and Shadow which is
something that Gemma said to him in the
prior movie it's sort of Lawrence of
Arabia's story and I love how big that
this trailer feels shot fully in IMAX we
even get the expanded aspect ratio for
this teaser and every single thing about
it feels like it's epic it's an
incredible new look at the upcoming
movie and I was blown away by just how
Grand this feels really can't wait to
sink my teeth into it and I've been
going back through the book The First
movie and that 84 version to get myself
back up to speed with Everything feels
like they're really gonna knock it out
of the park with this and we know that
June Messiah is possibly on the horizon
too hope that gets made as I think
there's so much to love about this
universe I can't wait to see what's in
store as we get down the line anyway
that wraps up the video lots of things
to unpack and make sure you leave your
comments on it below we are in a
competition right now giving away the
quantumania steel Buck the three
subscribers on the 15th of May and all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the teaser you pick the comments at
random on the 15th and the winners of
the last one are on screen right now so
that's you then message me on Twitter at
heavy spoilers if you want something
else to watch guess what we've just done
a big video on the Guardians post credit
scene so head over there right after
this if you've seen that movie let lots
of things to talk about about where
things can go in the future so yeah
hopefully you watch that after this and
if not you know what have a good day I'm
just going to end it nicely and you take
care yourself mate peace